bonsoir et bienvenue sur téléfils 78 il
est 18h si vous nous rejoignez en direct
en ce 2 janvier premier édition de
l'année 2013 l'ensemble de la rédaction
l'ensemble de tvfils 78 se joint à moi
pour vous souhaiter une excellente année
avant de recevoir à tout à l'heure au
cours de cette émission le maire de
Saint-Cyr-l'École pour évoquer la
création d'un nouveau quartier sur sa
commune évoquait également les
municipales je vous propose de vous
écouter quels sont vos vœux pour 2013 un
monde meilleur plus équilibré et du
travail pour tous
un peu plus d'optimisme général voilà
des vœux des vœux utopiques la paix que
personne n'est fin au moins voilà tout
le monde soit heureux dans la mesure du
possible quand gardons notre travail
surtout je pense que c'est vraiment
d'actualité et puis qu'on soit tous en
bonne santé voir un petit peu mes
enfants davantage ceux qui sont loin
et nous allons commencer cette première
édition de l'année par de la culture
bonsoir Maryvonne Taylor Picard
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous proposez
des stages de dessin de peinture à
Voisins le bretonneux pour tous les âges
ben justement on va parler de ses
ateliers de ces stages pendant les
vacances auparavant je vois vraiment
pour tous les âges que vous les proposez
ces rendez-vous ça veut dire qu'on peut
dessiner et peindre à n'importe quel âge
c'est tout à fait ça même si on n'y
connaît rien du tout comme moi on peut
venir et apprendre à dessiner
79 bientôt voilà vous me disiez lorsque
je vous ai eu cet après-midi pour
préparer cet entretien vous préférez
avoir justement des gens qui n'ont
qu'une base qui débutent plutôt que des
gens qui ont déjà quelques connaissances
oui parce qu'ils sont plus ISO qui sont
plus réfractaires à des thèmes bien
précis ils aiment divaguer un petit peu
avec leurs cartes leur sujet un peu
personnels et voilà ce sont déjà
contraintes et moi j'aime proposer des
thèmes différents à chaque fois c'est ce
que vous allez faire d'ailleurs sur les
prochains ateliers ce sera autour de la
fréquent on va y venir dans un instant
on va parler de votre atelier tout
d'abord arc-en-ciel les activités vous
proposer tout au long de l'année nous
verrons ça aussi tout à l'heure depuis
quand vous peignez quel est votre
parcours alors je peins depuis l'âge de
15 ans enfin approximatif avant je
dessinais après
une trentaine quarantaine d'années que
vous payez
c'est très naturel c'est venu
naturellement vous étiez déjà dans un
jardin mais que je n'ai jamais connu et
je pense que c'est dans la famille voilà
c'est le gène
à mon avis je n'ai jamais connu mon
grand-père mais j'admirais toujours ses
tableaux à la maison on envoie à l'écran
actuellement vous les voyez sur l'écran
juste en face de vous Maryvonne se sont
vos tableaux ce sont vos réalisations
vous pouvez nous en dire quelques mots
vous peignez dans dans quel registre
justement
je peins beaucoup de fleurs des
portraits c'est mon terrain de
prédilection
et beaucoup de paysages comment vous
travaillez alors je peins dans un
atelier à Félix art à Montigny que le
maire gentiment nous propose nous enfin
nous donne carrément dans une école et
voilà et chez moi bien sûr et ensuite
sur votre technique de peinture il faut
toujours un modèle ou aussi soit des
paysages que moi je photographie soit
mes photos soit sur sur site soit soit
mes enfants soit des gens que je connais
chez les commandes de portraits aussi
voilà l'atelier arc-en-ciel avoisin le
bretonneuse c'est le nom de votre
atelier arc-en-ciel vous l'avez fondé il
y a une dizaine d'années quel était le
but
mon mari est parti il y a une il y a 12
ans maintenant il fallait que je tombe
que je trouve une activité et c'était
vraiment celle que je préfère et
aujourd'hui ça fonctionne plutôt bien
c'est différents ateliers
une cinquantaine à peu près et les
élèves sont tous des débutants oh non
j'ai vraiment de tout enfin les enfants
c'est surtout des débutants
c'est vraiment j'ai aucun problème avec
les enfants et les ados c'est vraiment
un régal il y a des stages donc qui sont
organisés également pendant les vacances
on voit d'ailleurs quelques-unes des
réalisations des des élèves que vous
avez des plus jeunes les stages
différents quoi des ateliers qui ont
lieu tout au long de l'année alors
souvent c'est des thèmes qui sont un peu
plus longs mais qu'on a besoin de
plusieurs jours ou plusieurs après-midi
pour les réaliser donc comme les carnets
de voyage comme des thèmes qu'on peut
pas réaliser en une seule séance ou deux
séances
des illustrations de livres on fabrique
des petits livres aussi comment vous
travaillez justement avec les enfants on
parlait des débutants et qu'il était
plus facile avec les débutants tout à
l'heure mais avec les enfants mais il y
a des techniques pour les amener à
peindre on apprend toutes les techniques
on commence par le crayon bien sûr le
baba et puis après on essaie d'aborder à
peu près toutes les techniques sauf lui
là bien sûr parce que là c'est un peu
plus à l'essent donc là j'utilise des
pastels à l'huile pour les petits il
faut beaucoup de concentration quand on
peint aussi alors ce qu'on est enfant
c'est un petit peu difficile parfois
alors malgré tout
concentrés et d'autres qui sont qu'il
faut plus canaliser j'ai de tout
ils reviennent à la peinture quand ils
sont un peu plus j'ai un cadre bien bien
déterminé non non je laisse pas faire
n'importe quoi
ont du mal dans leur classe
c'est pas des classes de 30 donc en plus
ce sont des enfants qui sont qui aiment
peindre et qui viennent parce que ça
leur fait plaisir c'est pas comme de
force alors ça m'est arrivé j'ai fait
comprendre aux parents que ça marchait
pas du tout donc c'est pas une classe de
français et de maths
qui est un peu plus rébarbatif pardon
les profs de maths et français mais
c'est vrai que ce sont des enfants qui
sont partants d'eux-mêmes donc c'est
beaucoup plus facile qu'est-ce que ça
apporte justement aussi aux enfants à se
concentrer ça leur apprend à se
concentrer ça leur apprend les
techniques de base et en même temps elle
s'exprimer surtout surtout à s'exprimer
et donc vous dispensez les ateliers tout
au long de l'année on peut s'y inscrire
en condamné ou c'est mieux de le faire
en début en cours d'année
il y a aussi les stages pendant les
vacances pendant les vacances pardon
comme en ce moment et donc les prochains
stages les deux prochains rendez-vous
jeudi 3 et vendredi 4 janvier 14h à 17h
à Voisins-le-Bretonneux les coordonnées
ceux qui s'affichent à l'écran comment
vous allez travailler sur les deux
prochaines journées donc on va faire un
carnet de voyage en Afrique donc on va
faire des petits croquis comme si on
était en voyage en crayon aquarelle
encre et voilà ça comme si on était en
voyage et qu'on sais pas trop le temps
de finir ce qu'on fait donc c'est que
des petits croquis rapides il est encore
possible de s'y inscrire oui tout à fait
et ben voilà les coordonnées s'étend
affichées vous pouvez toujours vous
inscrire malgré tout ça coûte combien
est-ce que ça coûte cher alors pour pour
un adulte à dos c'est 36 € l'après-midi
et pour un enfant c'est 30 €. merci
d'être venu sur notre plateau Maryvonne
Taylor Picard donc que vous êtes peintre
et vous organisez ces stages ces
ateliers durant les vacances et aussi
tout au long de l'année du côté de
voisin le Bretonneux prochaine date les
trois et quatre janvier merci à vous
d'être venu pour débuter cette année et
on vous souhaite bien évidemment une
bonne